I saw an interview actually Stephen
Crowder
Canadian comedian had a mortician on did
you happen to see that interview I I'm
not no I'm not familiar with that one
well he had a mortician on and the
mortician was reporting that he is now
seeing these uh huge growth he actually
showed them he has captured a number of
them these huge growths from the
arteries of recently deceased people
they are apparently anomalous in his
experience he hasn't seen these things
before they superficially might be
called clots but they are chemically uh
not similar to what a normal not only is
the structure much larger in fact he
tells the story that he thought his the
pump that profuses a corpses with
formaldehyde was broken because it
couldn't push past these clots and when
he went after them he got these
gargantuan uh Alien looking things out
of people's
arteries I was wondering
um if you have heard anything like this
from the medical side no Dr Drew
actually mentioned this as well to me
and I've seen a few of these images but
um and they look very extraordinary and
nothing like I've seen before I haven't
um personally had anyone contact me or
any pathologist to suggest to me that
they've seen anything like this it
doesn't mean it's not happening
um but yeah I mean you know this is
again a novel technology and and we
don't know exactly all the kind of
things it's doing within the body and
certainly clotting abnormalities
themselves and it may be these are
unusual you know they have unusual
appearance are one of the most common
um serious Adverse Events from the
vaccine so Joseph Freeman who's a lead
author on that paper
published in vaccine where they did a
re-analysis and found this one in 800
figure he told me that actually within
that 1 800 figure 40 the most common
serious adverse event was related to
clotting so including things like heart
attack Strokes Pomme emboli so that's an
interesting you know um what you've
shared with me probably fits with that
but I don't know yeah I wouldn't be able
to comment on on the specific pathology
yeah
um you raise another issue though you
know a you know I don't know anything
about it professionally but
um these pseudo collapse or whatever
they are or maybe they are clots look to
like they must have accumulated over a
very long period of time and I'd be very
curious to know if that's true whether
they show up on scans this kind of thing
but the other issue is
you know another little place where the
Pharma game Alters our perception
is that there are claims about well you
know what is the commonality of
myocardinis following a second uh dose
of Pfizer for example well
that is not a good question because
myocarditis is diagnosed at some
threshold right presumably there's lots
of subclinical myocarditis maybe there's
even undetectable myocarditis and this
is not liable to be cost free in terms
of your longevity for example right so
if you have a little myocarditis not
enough to cause you to seek medical
attention
and then at some point in the future you
push your system Beyond some usual limit
maybe that turns into a critical
failure and won't be attributed to uh
the the cause from the so-called
vaccines and so I guess I'm I'm
wondering to what extent do you think
our crude measurement tools are missing
damage that will actually be significant
enough
um to alter longevity I think that they
are missing them to a large degree
breadth so I've managed many people in
the community who would not have had a
formal diagnosis of myocarditis because
of the vaccine because they develop
symptoms in the community that they
didn't Merit as being severe enough to
be hospitalized but clinically from the
history you could say it probably was
myopericarditis where you get
involvement of the outer layer of the
heart as well and that gives people
chest pain and they were very classic
one of my patients a lady in their 50s
actually developed
um within a cup two months of having the
vaccine very fit and well good no
problems in the background round
shortness of breath and then
echocardiogram an ultrasound scan of the
heart revealed that a heart muscle pump
function was severely impaired and again
from the history the most likely cause
was the vaccine
she again wasn't admit to hospital so I
suspect was probably probably quite a
lot of people out there that uh that are
you know who have vaccine damaged maybe
don't know it or certainly aren't coming
under this Statistics in the published
literature of say one in 2700 I think
that's the highest figure reported in
young males of prevalence of myocarditis
after the vaccine but that's
specifically people who are hospitalized
so you're right it's uh probably a lot
of people in the community who are
having vaccine damage as well and again
how this plays out in the long term we
really don't know but if there is any
scar on The myocardium which often
happens after myocarditis then that
could be a potential substrate for
rhythm distort disorders moving forward
I think one of the other things that's
worth mentioning as well Brett in terms
of you know I try first and foremost me
as a doctor as a physician is I want to
be the best possible doctor I can be for
my patient and there are two crucial
components to being a good doctor or
getting the best patient out outcomes
one is your history taking your clinical
history taking and the other is empathy
and the reason why history taking is
important is that eighty percent of your
diagnoses comes from the discussion with
a patient if you are a good doctor a
good doctor doesn't rely on tests to go
to test first a good doctor makes his
diagnosis predominantly or likely
diagnosis from the discussion and that's
really how um you know the the and that
concept interestingly a little anecdote
for you here my alma mater is University
of Edinburgh
the University of Edinburgh Medical
School was also
um they was known well known also
because one of its medical students
became a doctor was Arthur Conan Doyle
who is the author of Sherlock Holmes and
I are you aware of the link between
Sherlock Holmes and Medicine Brett do
you know about this story I don't think
so
so Sherlock Holmes's byline was this
and this is how he solved his murder
mysteries his you know who perpetrated
crimes and I say this is how we make
diagnosis
when you've eliminated the impossible
whatever remains
however improbable must be true
and if you if you apply that to Medical
Practice you'll never miss a diagnosis
the problem we've got certainly in
relation to the covert vaccine is that
doctors are not even conceiving of the
possibility that many of these problems
are related to the vaccine because
industry has hidden that data and
therefore it's not part of the
differential diagnosis once I became
aware of these possibilities from a who
World Health Organization endorsed list
of all these potential side effects
which again I list in in my paper then
you open your mind up to the possibility
that the vaccine could be a cause
because you've excluded other possible
causes so many people who are being
gaslighted or being told it can't be the
vaccine but they're being told I don't
have any explanation for why you will
know risk factors suddenly had a heart
attack or why you've not had a history
of a viral infection you've suddenly
presented with heart failure you know
the common denominator through the
history often is the vaccine and that's
how you make the diagnosis
a couple things in there worthy of
comment
um one is the rush to vaccinate
everybody complicates this if they had
succeeded in vaccinating everybody then
it obscures part of the pattern because
doctors wouldn't be able to detect some
difference between their vaccinated and
unvaccinated patients
[Music]
thank you